Hương trực bán biệt thương trình cầm tủ chỉ đạo lực lượng công an
tiếp tục phát way và thực hiện một số nhóm nhận vô
để bảo nạn ăn đi, ăn toàn trực đối cho đại hội
Thương trực bán biệt thương trình cầm tủ nhận mạnh
lẽ xuất quân và diễn tập là giống móc chuyển sản thái của toàn lực lượng
sản trở rộ sản trình đấu cao nhất
Hương trực bán biệt thương nhận mỗi cán bộ trên dưới
phải thống ngon mạnh lời hoài đây là giản dưới
và chết nghiệp lưỡng lào chức nạn và nhân dân
bù lẽ là một trong những công tác quan trọng của bộ con an
nhằm bảo nạn ăn toàn trực bối lại hội lòng với bối của đàn
giống ra từ nhằm bối chiến đến hành lòng tháng 1 xa tới
việc giữ tập các phương an bảo về an nình chắc tư phụ phụ đại hội đàn
là bước biệt thú đau nhằm lưng cao năng lực nằm bắt
phòng tích và giữ bảo tình hình
tư đó sẽ dựng các phương an tắt chiến thư tế
xong định chính xác các nục tiêu trọng biển cầm mò về
đây của là giúp tệ toàn lượng ra xuất
kìm chá tăng dựng hệ thống phương tiệch cho phép bị kiế phật và câu khủng hỗ trợ
bà đảm chẳng thái sẵn sản trên đấu cao nhất trong mọi tình ũn
biển cầy đó
tăng cường mối quan hệ phối hợp hiệp đồng và nạn thần thục cơ trễ tắt chiến giữa các nửa